[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome back to the explain series so
the galaxy s8 is a head-turning phone
and there are plenty of awesome new
things about it but one thing that kind
of went under the radar i don't even
know if it was officially said during
the announcement is that this is the
first phone in the world to ship with
bluetooth 5.0 so you've probably heard
of bluetooth and you may even know if
your phone has bluetooth 4.0 or 4.1 or
4.2 but generally those different
iterations of bluetooth are just slight
improvements to things like pairing time
and low energy modes etc it doesn't
really change the way you use it you
just know your phone has bluetooth but
5.0 that's a pretty big new number that
seems to signify sort of a bigger change
so there's a couple things that you
should know about so what is new with
bluetooth 5.0 there are three main
things that all enable one pretty dope
new feature so number one is it's two
times faster so bluetooth pairing is
generally not that quick of a process
you don't have to do it very often but
it's pretty slow if you're someone like
me who's connecting a lot of bluetooth
speakers as i test a bunch of them for a
video then you know that it's not super
quick but doing it with this galaxy s8
with bluetooth 5.0 shows a direct
advantage of data transferring twice as
fast which is the pairing process is a
bit quicker and there's also less delay
you ever watch a video like on bluetooth
speakers or bluetooth headphones and
like the audio is a little bit behind
the video like someone's talking and
then you hear it like a split second
behind it's usually not too bad but that
actually does get solved a bit with
bluetooth 5.0 that delay is a lot
smaller so that's data speed number two
is four times the range that's actually
been a real world weakness of bluetooth
especially in my past it depends on what
pair of headphones you use but sometimes
you can be listening to music in your
headphones and you leave your phone in
another room you walk a little bit too
far away and it starts cutting out and
then eventually stops that happens like
all the time the theoretical maximum
range of bluetooth 4 was about 50 meters
with a direct line of sight but about 10
meters in everyday use through walls and
around corners and around different
rooms of a house so 30 feet tops so that
means you can't get very far away from
your phone if you're trying to listen to
music or if you walk around the corner
it's going to cut out and that's kind of
annoying bluetooth 5 like i said
quadruples that max range so a
theoretical maximum of 200 meters with a
direct line of sight or about 40 meters
around a house or indoors so that's
that's 120 feet that's a legitimate
serious improvement so that's not just
like downstairs and around the corner
that's like you can walk out in your
backyard while your phone's upstairs you
can walk to the front yard around the
gym whatever you got to do you can get a
lot further from your audio source with
bluetooth 5.0 and then the number three
improvement is eight times the data
throughput of bluetooth four and this is
where a lot of the real world
improvements and dope features start to
get enabled so first of all this is
benefits way beyond just like audio like
i'm talking about speakers because
usually that's what we use bluetooth for
but bluetooth can also be used for
things like bluetooth beacons and
parking meters and small wireless things
those can also be helped by more data
throughput through bluetooth 5. but if
you think about a bluetooth stream like
a highway it used to be a two-lane
highway going 40 miles an hour for
20 miles
now it's a 16 lane wide mega highway
going 80 miles an hour for 80 miles it's
a completely different story so having
all these lanes of data moving so fast
enables a pretty sweet feature which
samsung calls and which we'll call since
they're kind of first to it dual audio
which lets you output to two
different bluetooth speakers
at the same time so let me demo that
real quick i'm going to connect to
bluetooth one at a time here
plays the sound whenever it turns on
so this is one speaker
it's pretty decently loud
but let's say i want that stereo
listening experience i want to have two
different outputs at the same time just
bear with me here i'm going to connect
this one now so you go into the dual
audio mode you turn it on and then you
make sure both of your sources are
connected that you want to play to turbo
is pad okay and we hit play
[Applause]
[Music]
so the fact that that works so easily is
awesome you might have noticed there's
this this super tiny delay in the the
audio timing one of them plays like a
tiny bit before the other one that can
be negotiated just by moving them
further apart you'll notice it way less
but yeah this used to be a lot more
difficult to do like you've heard of
sonos right sonos essentially made its
living of a couple of things but mainly
the fact that you could connect to a
bunch of different speakers all around
the house in different places at once
you had to get certain sono speakers and
you had to have that sonos app and then
you connect the app to the mesh network
that the sonos speakers create amongst
themselves and when you plug that into
those speakers then you'll get the one
audio source among several sonos but you
had to buy those very expensive sonos
speakers to make that happen this
bluetooth 5.0 and this feature enables
that sonos experience on any bluetooth
speaker so that is bluetooth five
more data more range and faster speeds
and it's good to know about a phone that
you may potentially get later this year
so that's pretty much it thank you for
watching talk to you guys the next one
peace
someone who likes this
[Music]